hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim okay we have an
objective we've got to go back in time
to save the future or something like
that we need to get the Elder Scroll to
go back in time anyway um I don't think
there was an actual word here I could
learn from this guy I know I skipped a
lot of dialogue let me go check me and I
will listen return it here to the T but
I believe this crows born then you will
feel you will see them huh huh who's fat
on my friends taken gone bleh the first
mortals that I taught that the first
they were always this guy in the
rebellion even - that's awesome tends to
defeat that we saw wrote the nodes have
had many heroes sense but none great Oh
what about me well I'm not ignored so I
could send that matter okay now I need
you'll find the super awesome mega
optional tough to iron out super mega
awesome double extra to Esbern talk to
her hunger optic darn gir super ultra
mega uber uber some I've totally lost my
train of thought there but it was
amazing whatever I was talking about I'm
sure it was phenomenal there's my noisy
dude my Doodle boy be glad it follows me
work
what's that
come on where you at buddy that you your
wolf car there he is I suppose if I have
to come here so I'll tell you what you
want to go golly
did he teach you huh so be it if he
believes it is necessary have never
concerned ourselves with the scroll aha
the gods themselves will as for where to
find it such blasphemous have always
been the stock and trade of the mages of
Winterhold okay they may be able to tell
you something about the Elder Scroll you
seek okay um well you just told me that
you have learned so much Rach come on
growing my gift
finding these lost words would be a
sufficient yes to temper your abilities
okay whatever someone said that I need
to press R on my shout and spend some
dragon souls on something er ah there we
go
unlock oh I've got oh there it is I got
two dragon souls okay
so now I spent it on that I I guess I
didn't really need it but Oh God now
let's go talk to as burn I suppose maybe
you'll be able to me more I mean the
mage guild suppose I actually did it did
quite a bit of me mage guild quests back
when I was [ __ ] around
and what wears oh oh I guess you
probably just gonna tell me to go the
maids bill - okay I need to go to winter
hole but first I need to go to Whiterun
because I need to sell my [ __ ] I have
way too much crap
hey look it's an Argonian look at that
handsome devil Oh
nighttime whoa Loney Loney understand
here stock still like a statue for 11
hours in this position and there we go
alright where is this baby is this
people where are these people
hello I need to sell some [ __ ] we've got
small one
hmm blades helmets pretty much anything
to suit your needs back on back on oh
well how long have I have the iron
daggers on me woodcutters axe i am i
rarely need that I don't even need that
that's just dead weight orcish bow or
dwarven bow although these are pretty
heavy too ass not that bad no big deal
no biggie
yeah I think cool for me no no nope nope
good doing business with you bad doing
visit with you I could buy a house I
suppose but I don't have the gold for
that I'm I don't have any goals at all
what no I don't want to freakin lock
what are you talking about
well fine I guess we'll go back since I
like spent all of my potions trying to
fight a dragon shut up you look ugly
pale potions and alchemy reagents okay
you can have that oh I do have quite a
bit of gold um no I'll keep that that
gone oh [ __ ] the word its one-handed but
whatever
I guess I could put poison on my weapons
how I'm a nice all right give me all
your health that's it that's it
these people I swear to mess with me
everyone's trying to mess with me no one
treats haven't robbed us to gods
oh come on how long do I have to wait
you are but such a thing surely that's
not possible
let me prove it to you No yo you're on
fire
are you are you stop right there and
they are sane oh I didn't realize it was
you look the other way this time oh the
yards influence has its limits be more
careful dog be more careful sorry sorry
about that that I lit you on fire if
it's a fight you want I'm ready this
time oh yeah get him Lydia get him he's
not doing anything
get him yeah no one saw anything I
didn't kill him
I didn't do anything okay finally okay
enough of that murder spree got
something just about everybody I love
everything's oh but it's just so pushing
us right oh thank you God okay why have
those still
those things there well I've got a lot
of friggin oh the all the Alto wines
I've been stocking up for some strange
reason gives no health that gives jail
that gives home leg off goat
all these give piddly amounts of health
but I guess I should focus on it a bit
more wine screw the wine alright
[Music]
all right I think that'll do for now do
come I don't have all the potions I want
but at least I have something and
somethings better than nothing
God these dragons I'm playing on expert
in case everyone was wondering man they
just tear me apart even though I'm a big
beefy Argonian they're just like are you
a [ __ ]
yeah yeah and then I have to die it's
real sad my horse he's still here there
is there is my orthey but I don't need
that guy's body is still there that's
very disturbing yeah I thought the
bodies faded after a while you do I can
take you to you though where do you want
to go where am I going
what was it going Winterhold that's
right climbing back and well diamond
packin filled BR screw you and your son
don't cares most of winterhold was lost
to the sea in the great collapse of for
eat 112 but the college was been left
mysteriously unharmed maybe it's full of
mages and that's why come on her see
it's a time' to ride
Lydia you walk graduate chicken
eww Oh oh yeah it's right here hello
lady excuse me pardon me need to get
through haha [ __ ] off lady I am moving
on excuse me while I ride my horse right
in here ah what the hell
what the hell fine I'll go back Lydia
get out of the way got [ __ ] to do give
me lady I'll pass your test
give it lady they know it is a dress
come back here top it off my horsey okay
may I add our nail their schools
uh-huh I said you're talking to be able
from way up there you know we could talk
closer
I don't smell that bad oh yeah yeah
Oh would you now ha ha ha ha fire so the
stories are true yeah you are normally
you'd need to show some I think there is
much that we can learn from each other
oh yeah I think you'll be a superb
addition to the college
welcome apprentice a practice you across
the bridge once you're inside you'll
want to speak with Mirabelle Irvine I'm
not so the stories are true yep you are
dragon yeah I know baby I get it all the
time everywhere I go
oh you're the Dragonborn
are you so fine then I go yeah baby I
know even that guy in Riverrun the guy
in the store that I got the claw back I
think is a crush on me
oh it's Paige give me your elder scroll
hello yeah my way you talk to it Oh up
here the are Carney um I think the
forest I got in this quest line was I
went down into the cellars and I beat up
some mysterious sparkly dude or
something I don't know
hey hi old man any of these books you
are now in the art King I now up to my
art cane are your Arcanum do you require
assistance elder scroll and what do you
plan to do learn it do you even know
what you're asking about it's a scroll
just someone's errand I'm the freaking
Dragonborn I knew it uh-huh everyone
comes in here an elder scroll as an
instrument of immense knowledge and
power so am I to read an elder scroll a
person must even so the Divine's usually
take the readers site as a price yeah
let them try the simplest way to put it
is it's a reflection of all possible
futures and all possible paths hmm each
reader sees different reflections
through different lenses and may come
away with a different but at the same
time all of it is true even the
falsehoods especially the falsehood that
doesn't make any sense bro it would take
a month to explain to you how that very
question make sense
well scary of that scrolls exist here
with us but also beyond and beneath
before and after they are bits of divine
made substance so we could know them
sorry
talking about the scrolls you usually
end up in irritating and vague metaphors
like that uh-huh
some people who study them devoutly go
mad like you you think that even if I
did have it would be kept under the
highest security yes thief in the world
wouldn't be able to what about wait are
you yeah you're the one the great birds
were calling as me
I'll bring your
think we have on them but it's not nice
to say drag mortal drops all come
running mostly lies Levin with rumor and
conjecture uh-huh oh come on
well where is it oh come on go get it
boy fetch it fetch it come on
I read you up there you go try not to
spill anything on them oh this is it
oh I have to read this oh it's just
widely known that among scholars
mechanism theories in nah brah just just
idiots Polonius I love a dichotomy
loving about a plain group of the first
no prophecy the astronomy impossible to
further investigate group of the second
unguarded intellects oh my goodness this
is a lot to read blah blah blah blah
blah
hit knowledge alone in Tamriel rigorous
mental cultivation mmm unguarded in Lex
oh my goodness it's so much my brain not
taking this oh oh
I've discovered something about the
insane book but it is in oh I want to
read this but it is in the very pushing
that you become a tree in spite of
yourself how did that happen the air
corn is some kind of a tree egg in this
instance the knowledge is water and Sun
we are the chicken inside the egg but
also the dirt all right what what each
of our minds is actually emptiness okay
all right taking this
hey buddy did you read this book it's
kind of insane riches layers I'm going
to assume that's the workup Septimus
Signet he's the world's master of the
nature of Elder Scrolls but well he's in
sans been gone for a long while
oh no no it came up set all David
Whalers took off north saying he had
found some old artifact North seen him
since where as far north as we queried
icefields if you want to try to find him
sure I'll try fine I'll find him in two
minutes while you're all singing inside
Oh where's my friend Oh No I've missed
him so much
oh he's old in a field somewhere where
you could have just found him in two
seconds if you actually gave a [ __ ] but
you did because you're a dick [ __ ] off
ah ha say Oh horsey where's this
Waypoint there I guess it is north got
my way you're I can smell a douche when
I see one don't ask about that out of my
way lady shut up
better be careful when I come running
there we go hey Dave let's go north this
is gonna end well
you got ants so well are they oh there's
a way down okay that's good
ah hey where did you go running off
horsey bumper for when that was a dragon
fighting you and Lydia just disappeared
good job on these you like half goat
aren't you
jump jump you jump there we go then job
jump jump
perfect excellent no phenomenal good job
horsey you're so great at what you do
okay it's some sort of cave ahead ah I
wonder if is where an old crazy hermit
might be living it's so crazy it just
might be true I got horsie it's set of
up horsie I'm gonna turn you into glue
horsy I swear oh man that actually is
fart noise ah get ready ice ice bogging
the ice perfect there we go oh well look
at this Wow
it's like he's been here the whole time
and your friends completely abandoned
you Septimus Cygnus Cygnus it's like wow
and then all of a sudden she's right
here
is he right here is he's right here oh
my god his friends don't give a [ __ ]
hahaha his friends just don't give a
[ __ ] okay unknown then rise to your
death uh-huh elder scrolls he higher
they absconded with them so
no one's nice all I know of uh-huh I
cannot go through it not poor cept oh I
am oh well yeah well here as in this
plane mundus time on the cosmological
scale well it's all nearby fantastic
don't make me hurt you
you're damn right has no fear of you but
as one block raises another you see this
master work of Septimus it's clever
among men but he is but an idiot child
compared to the dullest of the dwellin
where are the Dwemer lucky then they
left behind their own way of read in the
depths of black reach what have you
heard of black we know cast upon we're
dreamer hundred of 10 dev but not all
two things I have the round one for
tuning drama music is the edge of
lexicon for inscribing
fine Mazar and its Kaido what
imaginations there will read this trust
Septimus he knows you can know the
deepest doors of to glimpse the world
inside in eldest but whoever found a
loophole place the lexicon into there
but who this inside someone the scroll
for not even the stronger you look to
your left you see one way your but the
eldest this guy's just mumbling alright
whatever he gave me something that like
this
can I go in here so he gave me something
when the top level was built yeah
no more could be placed it was and is
maximal apex okay whatever guy if you'd
give me the keys
blank lexicon and then the attunement
sphere right okay this some other I'm
supposed to go out am I am I just being
sent somewhere else I have no idea
really so this crazy guy just gave me at
all the tools I needed to find and use
the elder scrolls without even asking
who I was that seems totally logical oh
look at that
oh it's a little cave in the mountains I
remember you in the mountains for
naughty boys look at my horse my horse
is amazing give it a lick mmm tastes
just like crazy I don't know how many
times
probably a lot from okay horsey where am
I even going the right way no I'm not
I'm going to please me the opposite of
right way gray wolf get stuffed
lady Wow Lydia hot damn Lydia why I did
not know you could run that fast you're
like Forrest Gump not too bright but man
you can run way up no okay
Rekha Frank do I get up the mountain
well damn it why I'm going this way
nothing's just stopped me
there we go here's the way go horsey go
go you can do it you can do a horsey
yeah I knew hah Mountain ah suck it up
horsey you're going the right way now go
go Wow
good job did not expect you to make that
okay Wow holy crap we're Z or Z what's
wrong with you horsey are you okay
you kind of got that mad look in your
eye well haha a good job horsey holy
crap oh crap
ah no oh ah no Lydia why didn't you save
it with your massive thighs massive
thighs
you could have slowed the ball it's okay
I'll just have to ride you out like that
dirty mind
that's sad
oh shut up Wolfie get some tough aren't
you you're on fire now that's right run
away give me your [ __ ] why do you have a
silver ring give me your [ __ ]
good job Lydia for once
is it like gotta be so far away from it
yeah MIT uh well I guess I'm just gonna
be running for a while
wish I had a horse where she died
technically I murdered it by pushing it
to go off of a mountain so that's my bad
not that's my bad so now I get to hoof
it more wolves and I need fus-ro-dah cuz
I got the amplified for Oh die or
something
he gave me more knowledge and
Paarthurnax did something to my stop
going left
I'm hands are off I'm going left
yeah I'm contracted whoa whoa that's a
big I'm going left
I don't know why what I am this is
phenomenal
there we go okay all right let's go I
don't even care about the other dragon
symbol I don't have time for that
gotta get to the Dwemer crap for the
Elder Scrolls to go back in time for
golfing I don't really know what but I'm
going for it
well there's something is that is that
where him speak am i close yeah it
would've but take like two seconds with
my horse
but had a horse which I don't anymore
Lydia ah turned our leaf else so what
did happen to the Dwemer something
happen to him right they're all dead
aren't they they were so smart they why
are they so dead ah okay there we go
perfect like Mouse not a big deal for me
let's save again just in case just in
case okay saved
or even metal ingot I'll take that sooo
last Journal oh so many words don't care
this looks like a trap all this
hello
nobody wants them
huh well say
auto research notes oh god don't care
this is also exciting and I don't care
the hell I don't know
nope at all hello hello
Wow Oh kill you
Wang si this is how you do it Lydia yeah
smash it to pieces you don't play around
you just yeah just smash it to pieces
no fooling I don't even think I'm going
the right way
hello Wampus Wampus Garnett yes
Verena another of the smooth schemes
looking for food do I look like I have
smooth skin
are you want some aah
you killed your friend kill your friend
No thank you for the potions and thank
you for not using all right that's
actually all the time I got for this
episode I will explore the deficit is
later and get the Elder Scrolls in the
next episode then thank you all so much
for water you for worrying for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
part
bye bye